>> Tucker: IF YOU SPENT ANY
TIME DRIVING AROUND AMERICA
RECENTLY, YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED THAT AN AWFUL LOT OF
AMERICA SEEMS TO HAVE SLIND
UP AND DIED.
TAKE A DRIVE AROUND MAINE
LOOK AT THE ABANDONED PAPER
HILL.
AND ELM TRI FACTORY RINGED
WITH BARBED WIRE.
OUTSIDE OF THE COASTAL
CITIES SCENES LIKE THIS ARE
EVERYWHERE.
THIS IS YOUR COUNTRY NOW.
SHUTTERED CAR DEALERSHIPS
NEXT NEXT TO DEFUNCT
RESTAURANTS AND METHADONE
CLINICS.
THAT'S AMERICA.
COMMUNITY AFTER COMMUNITY.
HUGE SWATHS OF THE UNITED
STATES LOOK LIKE THAT NOW.
SO WHAT HAPPENED?
WELL, A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENED.
SOME OF THEM ARE COMPLICATED
AND HARD TO CHANGE.
BUT ONE OF THE BIG FACTORS
IN THIS SLOW-MOVING DISASTER
IS THE UTTER TRANSFORMATION
OF THE WAY OUR LEADERS THINK
ABOUT THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
DURING THE LAST GILDED AGE,
125 YEARS AGO, AMERICA'S
RULING CLASS MAY HAVE BEEN
OSTENTATIOUSLY RICH AND THEY
WERE.
GO TO NEWPORT RHODE ISLAND
FOR PROOF.
IT WAS RECOGNIZABLE AMERICAN
CLASS.
TYCOONS ACCUMULATED FORTUNES
BUT THEY ALSO FELT SOME
OBLIGATIONS TO THE COUNTRY
AROUND THEM.
STEEL TYCOON ANDREW CANCER
NATIONY WROTE STEEL
LIBRARIES FOR THE
EDIFICATION OF PEOPLE
BENEATH HIM.
JOHN ROCKEFELLER AND OTHERS
SET ASIDE HUGE PORTIONS OF
THEIR WEALTH AND SOME CASES
PROPERTY TO MAKE THIS
COUNTRY BETTER.
YELLOW SCONE, ACADIA
NATIONAL PARK, ET CETERA.
MAYBE MOST SIGNIFICANTLY IN
JANUARY OF 1914, HENRY FORD
MORE THAN DOUBLED THE
PRO-VEILING FACTORY RAGE $5
FOR 8 HOUR DAY.
FORD DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT
BUT HIS COMPANY WAS
SUCCEEDING AND HE THOUGHT HE
SHOULD.
SOME HISTORIANS TRACE THE TO
THE AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS TO
THAT DECISION.
IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
IMAGINE A BIG COMPANY DOING
THAT ATTITUDES ARE TOO
DIFFERENT.
AVERAGE FINANCE MOGUL
WORKERS COSTS TO BE REDUCED
OR ELIMINATED ENTIRELY.
PRIVATE EQUITY ISN'T
BUILDING A LOT OF PUBLIC
LIBRARIES THESE DAYS.
INSTEAD THE MODEL IS
RUTHLESS ECONOMIC BAY
DISTRESSED COMPANY.
OUTSOURCE THE JOBS.
LIQUIDATE THE VALUABLE
ASSETS AND FIRE MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT AND ONCE THE
SMOKE IS DUMP TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER OFTEN IN ASIA.
HAPPENED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
MADE A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PHENOMENALLY RICH.
ONE OF THEM IS A HEDGE FUND
MANAGER PAUL SICKER WHO
ACCORDING TO FORBES HAS
AMASSED A PERSONAL FORTUNE
OF $3 BILLION.
HOW HE MADE THAT MONEY WAS
BY PURCHASING SOVEREIGN DEBT
FROM FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
COUNTRIES.
COUNTRIES THAT WERE IN
TROUBLE.
USUALLY AT A MASSIVE
DISCOUNT.
ONCE THE COUNTRY GAINS ANY
STABILITY.
BOMBARD GOVERNMENT WITH
LAWSUITS AND MASSIVE PUBLIC
RELATIONS CAMPAIGN
ORIGINATING HERE IN
WASHINGTON UNTIL HE MADE HIS
MONEY BACK WITH INTEREST.
THE PRACTICE IS CALLED
VULTURE CAPITALISM.
FEEDING OFF THE CARCASS OF A
DYING NATION.
IN SOME WAYS NOT SO
DIFFERENT WHAT SINGER AND
HIS FIRM ELLIOTT MANAGEMENT
HAVE DONE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND TO THIS COUNTRY.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
DECADES ELLIOTT MANAGEMENT
HAS MADE BILLIONS BY BUYING
LARGE STAKES IN AMERICAN
COMPANIES, THEN FIRING
WORKERS, DRIVING UP
SHORT-TERM SHARE PRICES AND
IN SOME CASES TAKING
GOVERNMENT BAILOUTS INSULT
TO INJURY.
BLOOMBERG NEWS ONCE
DESCRIBED SINGER AS QUOTE
THE WORLD'S MOST FEARED
INVESTOR.
AND THAT TELLS YOU A LOT.
NO ONE IS EVEN PRETENDING
PAUL SINGER'S TACTICS ARE
GOOD FOR ANYONE BUT PAUL
SINGER AND HIS FUND.
CONSIDER THE CASE OF DELPHI,
THE AUTOMOTIVE PARTS
SUPPLIER.
DURING THE LAST FINANCIAL
CRISIS, THE CONSORTIUM OF
HEDGE FUNDS INCLUDING
SINGER'S ELLIOTT MANAGEMENT
PURCHASED DELPHI.
WITH SINGER AND THE OTHER
FUNDS AT THE HELM, THE
COMPANY TOOK BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN GOVERNMENT
BAILOUTS PAID FOR BY YOU.
OBAMA'S AUTO CZAR COMPARED
THOSE TACTICS TO EXTORTION.
BUT THEY CONTINUED ANYWAY.
ONCE THEY HAD THE BAILOUT
MONEY, THE FUNDS MOVED MOST
OF DELPHI'S JOBS OVERSEAS
AND THEN EITHER CUT RETIREE
PENSIONS ENTIRELY OR SHIFTED
THE COST TO TAXPAYERS.
WITH LATER FINANCIAL
COMMITMENTS AT HOME AND
CHEAP FACTORIES ABROAD,
DELPHI'S STOCK SOARED.
ACCORDING TO INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER GREG PALACE OF THE
25 DELPHI PLANTS WHEN THEY
STARTED BUYING DELPHI'S
DEBT.
ONLY FOUR WERE STILL
OPERATING IN THE UNITED
STATES BY 2012.
THAT MEANS TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF UNIONIZED AND WHITE
COLLAR WORKERS LOST THEIR
JOBS.
PAUL SINGER'S HEDGE FUND
CASHED OUT FOR MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
WELL SOME COUNTRIES
INCLUDING THE UNITED KINGDOM
HAVE BANNED THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
IT BEARS NO REACCEPT BLABS
WHATSOEVER TO THE CAPITALISM
WE WERE PROMISED IN SCHOOL
IT.
CREATES NOTHING.
IT DESTROYS ENTIRE CITIES.
IT COULDN'T BE UGLIER OR
MORE DESTRUCTIVE.
WHY IS IT STILL ALLOW YOU
HAD IN THE UNITED STATES?
THE SHORT ANSWER BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE PAUL SINGER HAVE
TREMENDOUS INFLUENCE OVER
OUR POLITICAL PROCESS.
SINGER HIMSELF WAS THE
SECOND LARGEST DONOR TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN 2016.
HE HAS GIVEN MILLIONS TO A
SUPER PAC THAT SUPPORTS
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
YOU MAY NEVER HAVE HEARD OF
PAUL SINGER WHICH TELLING
YOU A LOT IN ITSELF.
IN WASHINGTON HE IS ROCK
STAR FAMOUS.
AND THAT MAY BE WHY HE IS
ALMOST CERTAINLY PAYING A
LOWER EFFECTIVE TAX RATE
THAN YOUR AVERAGE FIREMEN
JUST IN CASE YOU ARE STILL
WONDERING IF OUR SYSTEM IS
RIGGED.
OH YEAH IT IS.
TONIGHT WE WANT TO TELL YOU
MORE ABOUT HOW PAUL SINGER
DOES BUSINESS.
STORY BEGINS IN A SMALL TOWN
CALLED SYDNEY NEBRASKA.
POPULATION 6282.
TWO HOURS OUTSIDE DENVER,
SYDNEY IS THE LONG-TIME HOME
OF A SPORTING GOODS RETAILER
CABELA'S WHICH SELLS FISHING
AND HUNTING GEAR.
DISCLOSED 11% STAKE IN DA
BELLAS PUSHING THE BOARD TO
SELL THE COMPANY.
CABELA'S MANAGEMENT
APPEARING A LONG AND COSTLY
FIGHT WITH SINGER ANNOUNCED
IT WOULD LOOK FOR A BUYER.
AT THE TIME CABELA'S WAS A
RELATIVELY HEALTHY COMPANY.
POSTING NEARLY $2 BILLION A
YEAR IN GROSS PROFITS OFF
$4 BILLION IN REVENUE.
IT DIDN'T SEEM TO BE ANY
IMMEDIATE NEED TO SELL.
BUT CABELA'S SOLD ANYWAY
AFTER BEING PUSHED.
SO ONE YEAR AFTER SINGER
ENTERED THE EQUATION, BASS
PRO SHOPS ANNOUNCED THE
PURCHASE OF CABELA'S.
THE COMPANY'S STOCK PRICE
SURGED.
WITHIN A WEEK.
LITERALLY A WEEK PAUL SINGER
CASHED OUT.
BOUGHT THE STOCK FOR $38 A
SHARE.
SOLD IT FOR $63 A SHARE.
HIS HEDGE FUND MADE
$93 MILLION UP FRONT AND
LIKELY MORE OVER TIME.
IN SIDNEY, NEBRASKA IT WAS A
DIFFERENT STORY.
THE RESIDENTS OF SIDNEY DID
NOT GET RICH.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
TOWN WAS DESTROYED.
LOST NEARLY 2,000 JOBS.
HEART BREAKINGLY FAMILIAR
CASCADE BEGAN.
PEOPLE LEFT, PROPERTY VALUES
COLLAPSED AND THEN PEOPLE
COULDN'T LEAVE.
THEY WERE TRAPPED THERE.
ONE OF THE LAST THRIVING
SMALL TOWNNESS THIS COUNTRY
WENT UNDER.
WE RECENTLY SENT TWO
PRODUCERS TO SIDNEY,
NEBRASKA TO SURVEY THE
WRECKAGE THERE AND CONSIDER
WHAT HAPPENED.
OUR PRODUCERS WANTED TALKED
TO MORE THAN A DOZEN
CABELA'S EMPLOYEES.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM REFUSED
TO SPEAK TO US ON CAMERA ALL
FEAR OF PAUL SINGER.
OFF CAMERA THEY TOLD US
THEIR STORY.
HERE IT IS.
>> SIDNEY, IT'S A GREAT
PLACE TO BE.
>> THIS IS SIDNEY, NEBRASKA,
A SMALL TOWN TWO HOURS
OUTSIDE OF DENVER.
FOR DECADES THE SPORTING
GOODS RETAILERS CABELA'S
KEPT HIS HEADQUARTERS IN
SIDNEY.
AS THE CORRESPONDENT GREW
MORE PROS OFFICER RUSS SO
DID THE TOWN.
>> BIG TIME OPPORTUNITIES.
>> Tucker: MOTTO WAS TURNED
ON HEAD ELLIOTT MANAGEMENT
HEDGE FUND MANAGED BY PAUL
SINGER TOOK AN OWNERSHIP
STAKE IN CABELA'S.
>> WHEN WE GOT THE NEWS THIS
COMPANY IS COMING IN FROM
NEW YORK CITY AND BUYING A
HUGE STAKE IN CABELA'S, THAT
SHAKES THINGS UP.
>> AT THE TIME CABELA'S WAS
MAKING MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
BUT PAUL SINGER'S FIRM
SENSED IT COULD MAKE A QUICK
BUCK BY DRIVING UP THE STOCK
PRICE BY FORGING A MERGER.
ONCE THRIVING TOWN OF SIDNEY
LOST EVERYTHING.
>> I CRIED THE SECOND I GOT
THE PHONE CALL.
I COULDN'T HELP IT.
I BAWLED.
>> Tucker: THAT'S HOW A LONG
TIME CABELA'S EMPLOYEE
REACTED WHEN SHE LOSING HER
JOB.
>> THAT WAS MY FUTURE.
AND NOW I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT MY FUTURE IS.
>> PROBABLY LOOKING AT
AROUND 2,000 JOBS.
>> 2,000 JOBS GONE?
>> Tucker: SIDNEY WAS
DEVASTATED.
>> HE RUINED IT.
A GOOD AMERICAN TOWN.
AND JUST DESTROYED IT.
>> Tucker: RUNS THE TOWN'S
LUMBERYARD.
BEFORE THE MERGER, BUSINESS
WAS GREAT.
>> WE WERE BURIED, YOU KNOW,
WITH BUSINESS.
>> Tucker: NOW HIS CUSTOMER
BASE HAS COLLAPSED.
>> HOW MANY NEW HOMES HAVE
BEEN BUILT SINCE CABELA'S
AND BASS PRO HAVE MERGED.
>> ONE.
>> ONE HOUSE?
>> ONE HOURS.
>> Tucker: BEFORE PAUL
SINGER'S HEDGE FUND IN ITS
SIGHT.
BUILDING BOOST.
>> NEW HOUSING SUBDIVISION
TO MEET HOUSING NEEDS.
ALL THESE GREAT THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
INSTEAD, WE ARE WORKING OUR
TAILS OFF TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO SURVIVE.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE OF SIDNEY,
IT'S BEEN A DISASTER.
THOSE WHO WANT TO LEAVE
SIDNEY CAN'T GO.
HOUSING VALUES ARE COLLAPSED
DID HE THEY'RING THEM THERE.
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO STAY
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE IMPOSSIBLE
TO FIND A NEW JOB.
>> HOW LONG DID IT TAKE YOU
TO FIND A JOB.
>> JUST SHY OF FIVE MONTHS.
>> IS IT AS GOOD AS YOUR OLD
JOB.
>> NO.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> Tucker: IF SIDNEY
COLLAPSED WALL STREET
CASHED.
IN SINGER SOLD OUT BEFORE
THE COMPLETE.
THE FUND MADE $100 MILLION.
>> THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT RURAL
NEBRASKA, SMALL TOWN.
>> I HOPE PAUL SINGER IS
PROUD OF WHAT HE DID.
IF MONEY IS THAT BIG OF A
GOD TO HIM.
HE IS A PRETTY SICK HUMAN
BEING.
>> Tucker: AS WE WERE DOING
THAT STORY, WE WERE WARNED
REPEATEDLY BY PEOPLE AROUND
WASHINGTON, DON'T CRITICIZE
PAUL SINGER.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
AND AS THAT PACKAGE PLAYED I
GOT THE FOLLOWING TEXT FROM
A VERY WELL-KNOWN PERSON IN
WASHINGTON.
HOLY SMOKES I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU ARE DOING.
THIS I'M AFRAID OF POWERFUL
SINGER.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BEN SASSE, THIS MAY POINT TO
THE POINT -- THE TEXTER WAS
MAKING.
BEN SASSE IS A U.S. SENATOR
WHO REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
NEBRASKA.
SIDNEY ISN'T THAT LARGE.
YOU MIGHT THINK THE DEATH OF
HIS TOWN IN HIS STATE MY
MIGHT BE A CONCERN TO BEN
SASSE.
A SENATOR FROM NEBRASKA.
SO FAR IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
HE HAS EVER COMMENTED WHAT
HAPPENED TO SIDNEY.
WE LOOKED HARD AND SEE IF
THERE WAS A TIME WHERE HE
COMMENTED ON THE DESTRUCTION
OF SIDNEY OR SUPPLY A
STATEMENT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THERE.
BEN SASSE'S OFFICE DIDN'T
EVEN RESPOND TO OUR
PRODUCERS.
THAT'S ODD.
BUT THEN HERE IS ONE
POSSIBLE EXPLANATION FOR